it is honestly incredible to think how
much information we got from the over 14
minutes hogwarts legacy gameplay reveal
however there are still some big
questions some major questions i would
say that are being asked by fans about
the game so in today's video we're gonna
go through seven things we still don't
know about hogwarts legacy number one
and this is absolutely the question that
i am seeing by far the most and that is
is quidditch in the game i'll be totally
honest watching the gameplay reveal live
i thought it was confirmation of
quidditch i really did i thought that
first shot of that character flying on
the broom in the quidditch robes with
the quidditch pitch in the background i
mean i took that as confirmation and yet
it was never actually confirmed in the
trailer we never see anyone actually
playing quidditch despite it being in
the background despite seeing some
characters walk around in quidditch
robes in quidditch gear never explicitly
stated that it is in the game and so the
more i've actually thought about this
the more i'm kind of getting a little
concerned that it may not be in the game
which pains me to say because i know how
many people want it to be in the game so
let me know down in the comments if
quidditch is not in the game how big of
a deal is that to you do you care i mean
i honestly will love the game with or
without quidditch i don't need quidditch
to be in the game in fact i feel like
quidditch world cup really helped to
show that quidditch is almost one of
those things that needs a dedicated game
around it and considering that hogwarts
legacy is a game where we get to sort of
choose the wizard we want to be what if
we're a wizard who doesn't want to play
quidditch you know i mean the fact that
we're starting as a fifth year we may
not even know what quidditch is we don't
know if our character grew up in a
wizarding family we don't know anything
about that yet so for me it would almost
be a little bit strange if they devoted
all this time and resources into
something that was a completely optional
activity that a large portion of fans
may completely ignore now that being
said given how many of you i know want
this i don't think it would be something
that a lot of people ignore but the
reality is that it would definitely be
something difficult to put into the game
if you think about all the different
positions back when we were playing the
original harry potter games all you had
to worry about was seeker you didn't
have to worry about setting up all the
other positions except in which world
cup of course but for the harry potter
movie tie-in games it was always you're
just the seeker and that's it so i know
i'm kind of waffling back and forth here
guys because i really don't know i mean
i feel like they've dropped enough hints
that it should be in but then given the
length of that trailer and all that they
confirmed why wouldn't they have
anything about quidditch in there in
terms of the faq in terms of the actual
trailer itself no one actually seen
playing quidditch just the pitch itself
and then another potential idea is that
maybe this is something they'll release
post launch as a possible dlc i don't
know i'm still holding out hope that
they'll be able to fit it into the main
game but if they don't it's not a deal
breaker for me i know you guys will let
me know what you think for me though
there's another question that is the
single most important thing honestly
this is more important than anything we
saw in the 14 minute gameplay reveal and
that is how does it actually play how
does it feel to play this game how well
does it run in terms of a pure reveal i
thought they absolutely knocked it out
of the park they showed me everything i
wanted to see except for maybe quidditch
but one of the things you just can't
possibly show in a setting like this or
i guess you can't really help someone
feel and that is how it actually plays
how tightly does our character control
how does it feel to shift between the
different spells i've heard a lot of
people asking about the different spells
and how we're going to cycle between
them one thing i absolutely love about a
lot of what i saw in this and i hope
this stays true for the final game is
that there was very little hud in the
game at all now i know there are a lot
of folks who are just fans of harry
potter that may not be familiar with
video game terminologies or like what is
a hud exactly well that's short for
heads up display so if you look at a lot
of games these days they're sort of
riddled with all sorts of menus like
your health and like a magic meter
different button combinations telling
you what to press for your different
spells i mean just pull up the old harry
potter games and you'll see exactly what
i'm talking about however everything we
saw here with hogwarts legacy the menus
were very minimal which i absolutely
love and one of the things that makes me
think it will actually be like this in
the final game is that when the
character gets hit you can sort of see
the outside of the screen turn red like
there's kind of blood almost coming onto
the screen and to me i think that is
their health meter that is their way of
showing that you're getting injured and
you could be about to die and you need
to take a reviving potion or something
so that's one component of this then we
also have the companion component
they've confirmed that it is officially
single player game no multiplayer
elements however we will have npc
companions so how will they factor into
the gameplay and as they're fighting
alongside us in battle we saw that we're
going to be able to use magical
creatures in battle and even magical
plants in battle which i love seeing
this and more than anything for me that
gets me excited in terms of the gameplay
i think is the combat i just did not
expect so much variety in terms of the
combat i mean that moment in the trailer
where the character used a pug node to
send the sword flying back through the
night i just thought that was such an
incredible moment but how does it
actually feel to pull that off in real
time while you're playing the game is it
intuitive does it make sense they did
confirm in the playstation blog post
that there will be varying difficulty
levels so for those of us who want more
of a challenge i think we're gonna have
that opportunity in hogwarts legacy but
again it all comes back to how it plays
what exactly does it mean to have a hard
mode is it just more health bars on the
enemies or do they actually have
completely different attacks all of that
remains to be seen and for me any time
with video games that is always going to
be the most important thing it's more
important than graphics it's more
important than presentation it's more
important than story because at the end
of the day i mean we're going to be
spending 10 20 30 40 50. who knows maybe
hundreds of hours potentially in this
world if it doesn't feel fun to play
then all of this other stuff is gonna
fall away honestly it's one of my
biggest problems with the witcher and i
know the witcher wild hunt the most
recent game is some people's favorite
game of all time and i love the game i
really do i love everything about it
except for the combat and how it
actually feels when you're moving about
the world i just could never get over
the combat in the witcher it never felt
right to me and i still like the game
like i still hold it in high regard but
that's really what kept it from being an
incredibly one of my all-time favorite
games and just a sort of pretty good
game instead now if you guys have
watched my live reaction to the trailer
you know that the biggest jaw-dropping
moment for me was when they revealed the
player character using avada kadavra as
someone who has been covering hogwarts
legacy here on youtube for quite some
time now i can tell you one of the
biggest requests that i always see is
people want to know how dark can i go in
this game is avada kadabra in and they
just straight up confirmed it i love
that that was an epic moment i'm glad
they included it but that leaves the
question of are the other unforgivables
in the game crucio and imperio i
honestly was totally surprised to see
avada kadavra in there so i wouldn't
have predicted all three of them to be
in there but now that they've showed
avada cadaver i'm kind of having to
rethink that a bit okay maybe they
actually will include these but here's
what's interesting when you look at
imperial and crucio imperio actually is
a spell that that's one that makes total
sense within a video game world for you
to be able to take control of another
character across the room i mean we've
seen this in a ton of video games they
don't call it the imperious curse but
we've seen different types of mechanics
or moments in a game where you take
control of another character to maybe
solve a puzzle or to get across a room
whatever it may be right crucio on the
other hand though is a spell purely used
for torture i mean that's what it is i'm
trying to think of some other games i
mean maybe grand theft auto there's a
couple of iffy moments in there with
some pretty intense violence so i
struggle to see how crucio would be used
as far as gameplay goes now if you think
about games like the walking dead story
driven games where you have to make
these big time choices maybe that is a
way that they could incorporate crucio
maybe there's a story moment where you
have to make a choice in what type of
spell or what path you're going to take
to maybe get some information out of
someone do you befriend them do you go
out and help them solve one of their
problems so that they will give you
information in return or do you just
straight up use cruzio to get the
information out of them maybe that's a
story branching moment where they could
incorporate crucio in that way now who
knows maybe they're going to go all out
maybe you're actually going to be able
to run around hogwarts and just cruisio
students left and right but if they go
that far then they're going to have to
be consequences right within the world
obviously the teachers aren't going to
let that happen it's an unforgivable
curse does the ministry swoop in does
the headmaster expel you immediately do
you get an in-game screen if you do that
how do they incorporate that into the
game that's what i can't wait to see now
in the gameplay trailer they did a
phenomenal job of showcasing hogwarts we
got to see the four different common
rooms we got to see the hogwarts
kitchens we got to see the prefects
bathroom they showed so many iconic
areas but one of the most iconic areas
in the entire series outside of hogwarts
that we did not get confirmation on is
diagon alley so that is my next big
question is diagon alley in the game now
if you think about the original series
where diagon alley really plays a
prominent role of course as in the start
of harry's journey he is introduced to
the wizarding world through diagon alley
but we already know that our character
is going to be taking a very different
path in terms of being introduced i
don't know about to the wizarding world
all we really know is that they're
taking a different path to hogwarts by
the fact they're starting as a fifth
year so maybe it doesn't make sense at
least at the beginning of the game to
have diagon alley as kind of the start
of our journey like it was with harry's
who knows maybe they will maybe they'll
surprise me but from everything we've
seen so far i don't get the idea that
diagon alley is in at least at the
beginning of the game now on the other
side of that though we did see a moment
in the trailer in what is clearly
gringotts actually two moments really
and what are pretty clearly gringotts
and we know that gringotts is in diagon
out so even though gringotts is pretty
much confirmed i still don't know if
that confirms diagon alley and the
reason for that is because of those
portals that we see early in the trailer
maybe those portals somehow relate to
the ancient magic that our character is
able to manipulate and master so i think
those portals will be how we get inside
gringotts so i don't know if we will
actually venture out into the other
areas of diagon alley or if it will just
be gringotts don't get me wrong i hope
they're able to include all of it in the
game i'm just trying to think about from
what we've seen so far what kind of
clues can we piece together to try and
figure out is diagon alley actually in
the game or not and so far in this video
i've alluded a couple of times to our
character and their sort of unusual
start to hogwarts and that leads me to
my next big question what did the main
character survive this is clearly a
question they want us to be asking they
talked about this in the blog post and
even almost answered and chandler sort
of stopped the person short of answering
at least that's how they show it in the
quotes is like no no we're not going to
reveal that just yet but all they're
saying right now is that our character
has an unusual start to their hogwarts
career so when they say you start in
year five that's kind of head scratching
right people like why would you start at
hogwarts in year five what sort of
circumstances could there be leading up
to that was our character a squib are
they a muggle who knows nothing about
magic did they attend another magic
school and now they're coming to
hogwarts for some different type of
reason i think those are all totally
valid questions but it seems like the
biggest question that we should be
asking is what did they survive they
survived something significant so
significant that apparently our
character actually starts hogwarts in a
way similar to harry they're almost a
celebrity so the other characters are
going to know the main character when
they arrive does it have something to do
with the goblins or does it is it
something completely different
unfortunately i do think it almost
certainly involves death so perhaps
someone in the main character's family
actually passes away and that's
something that kicks off the start of
the game and the reason we know this is
because our character can in fact see
and interact with thestrals later in the
gameplay trailer so as far as story goes
for me that's an incredibly big question
that i can't wait to see the answer to
now jumping back to gameplay here for
number six one of the hopes and dreams
that i see from so many of you in the
comments is that we will be attending
the final three years of our character's
career at hogwarts so we know we're
starting as a fifth year so how long
will the game be i have maintained for
quite some time that i believe it will
just be a single school year and i don't
know maybe this is just the habit of
like harry potter games and harry potter
books right they always sort of took
place over the span of one year that's
just how harry potter has traditionally
worked but for me i just think it makes
a lot of sense to have it only take
place over one year a lot of people are
talking about wizarding world careers
and going on after hogwarts and trust me
i'm right there with you guys i would
absolutely love that but i think that is
way too much to tackle in this one game
and if you read the playstation blog
post they hint very strongly i mean i
don't even know if i would say hint they
pretty much state hey we want to do more
in this universe but we have to have
your support you guys have to buy this
game you have to support this game and
if we do if this game sells well guys i
think it's very clearly going to get dlc
and possibly sequels as well and to me
that is where i think you start to
explore those conversations up do we
look at a sixth year do we look at a
seventh year which is when dumbledore
should be arriving at hogwarts do we
look at post hogwarts because trust me i
am as excited as you guys are about
seeing a game that is able to completely
go past hogwarts into so many different
other areas of the wizarding world but i
think that is a topic for another day
the focus of this game is almost
certainly hogwarts itself as they talk
about in the trailer and in the little
director's reveal afterward and in case
you guys didn't see hogwarts legacy
actually is available for pre-order at
least in the us i've heard from some of
my uk friends that it's not up there
just yet keep an eye out guys i'm sure
it's only a matter of time i'll post
some links down in the description where
you can pre-order the game if you want
to go ahead and do that i know some
people hate pre-orders i get it if you
don't want to pre-order that's fine but
for the people that do i'm going to put
that down there but this actually leads
me to the next question and the reason i
haven't pre-ordered yet is because i
want to know will there be a collector's
edition we did a video on this several
months ago about what i think would be
some really cool things to include in a
collector's edition and in a world so
rich so full of lore like hogwarts like
harry potter there is an absolute
plethora of different things they could
include in this collector's edition that
would be awesome so i hope that they
know this i think that they know this
the fact that the game is coming
later this year if they are working on a
collector's edition that's something
that we should start to hear about soon
and to anyone at avalanche or wb who may
be watching this if you do a collector's
edition please make sure you have a
clear pre-order plan for us because
trust me there are going to be a lot of
people interested in this collector's
edition and the last thing you want to
happen is the whole ps5 pre-order fiasco
again where nobody knows when they're
going live and then a bunch of people
who want them miss out and the scalpers
buy them up we do not want that i've
already had fans hitting me up on
twitter saying hey please when you hear
about the pre-orders for collector's
edition let me know so if there's any
way that wb and avalanche could kind of
give us a little bit of lead time on
that and say hey this is happening
here's the day it's going to go up that
would be awesome because i absolutely
think these are gonna sell and they're
gonna sell big so please avalanche
collector's edition make it happen so
today we talked about seven big
questions that i still have about
hogwarts legacy but did you know there
are actually 55 things you may have
missed in that 14 minute gameplay
trailer if you want a full breakdown of
that trailer and all the little secrets
that i found check out the video on the
right side of your screen now as always
guys thank you all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon